i got to ask you guys so i'm i'm
thinking one of the first times that i
noticed
funny stuff on the web somebody showed
me a guy named liltario right it was
diet it's like a little guy he has
diabetes but he got that
oh yeah it's like bankroll pj's dad
right um what's he doing now is he lost
weight oh
so that started ooh kill him and get
buckets right that's what so
that's where both of those things that
was your first video that's the first
thing i ever saw when somebody showed me
that and it just blew my mind i didn't
know what was going on
what was that dude's name um
unforgivable oh [ __ ] himself
that was like the first thing i ever saw
on youtube that was that was like the
first thing of like comedy comedy i saw
dudes in the woods and he's just he's
like you [ __ ] and tell me you had no
brother
yeah that's how you've never seen it
it's like yeah yeah
i went to levine just like get some
pants for me and my [ __ ]
i was gonna steal my hair no money
met a girl there trying on some skirts
i was like what that smell like
she was like she didn't know what to say
i'm like [ __ ] don't make me ask you
again
anyway got her number the next day we
went to chicken fillet
some place in the mall when i got that i
was like [ __ ] for all these people i
heard
about the leopard he said yeah he's
trying to watch the mall i'm like
whatever [ __ ] give me a chicken
sandwiches some waffle fries
[Laughter]
is this the republican national
convention is this blair witch
iv what the [ __ ] is that this is blair
[ __ ]
bro that was like 10 or 12 years ago it
was a chocolate rain area
my first one was you remember it was i
think it was a news uh
station and they thought they saw a
leprechaun in the tree
like who who saw the leprechaun i think
it sounded like time say yeah
who else seen a leprechaun say yeah yeah
well just in time for saint patrick's
day crowley is the first
to get another birmingham what some say
is a piece of
irish folklore some people in the
crichton area of mobile say
a leprechaun is taking up residence in
their neighborhood
a leprechaun
they're both freaking out curiosity
leads to large crowds in mobile's
crichton community
many of you bring blood oh i have
something cool
to take pictures to me it look like a
leprechaun to me i got to look up in the
tree who else in the black
and that changed the world bro oh yeah
then you went to bars
after like
dude and then they had i remember so and
then we'll get enough of watching some
videos finally but uh
but yet what was andrew's oh yeah what
was yours andrew
sorry about what for your first like
like comedy
like viral comedy yeah uh i got
when i was in like fifth grade i was
really into atheist youtubers
it was like really i was like yeah [ __ ]
yeah because i had kind of a religious
upbringing of my grandma she's a
presbyterian
so i found these atheist neckbeard guys
on youtube
yelling at the camera about how god
isn't real and i was like [ __ ] yeah
i don't think i got into comedy until
much later it all began with atheist
youtubers
i've never said that on record before
yeah no homo dog that's just chill bruh
get it off your chest man thank you guys
i appreciate it dude you feel better now
yeah i feel better good man
dude yeah i used to go look at
pornography in the library when i was
young
i'd look at the art books that have
drawings pictures of like rubenesque
women
tell me what you do with your dick dude
i would take my penis and put it in the
book right
and this is my penis was real real hard
yeah and then i would squeeze the book
against
it bro and that pressure would just get
me up and get me off
leather bound books are just like
paperback no nice books man
yeah yeah look at that right there
that's what you're talking about you can
always know how to find a tit when
you're a child like that
in your house you're like oh natural
geographic page 47 yes oh there's a dude
there's fireside tits bruh yeah and you
catch the flame hitting a freaking long
titty just right bro
bus nation son you know what i'm saying
ain't no laws for these balls
[Music]